una emotiva ceremonia aquí en los
jardines de luxemburgo a la que asistió
en lo presidente manuel pero él no tomó
la palabra una ceremonia que comenzó y
terminó en música gracias a christina
salem ella es una cantante de la isla de
la reunión esta isla en el océano índico
y cantó en un estilo que se llama malo y
a malo ya que es un estilo que nació
entre los esclavos precisamente de esa
isla también hubo lecturas de textos de
poemas por parte de los diferentes
estudiantes del colegio que vinieron de
todas las regiones del país para
participar en esta ceremonia textos
sobre el tema de la libertad sobre el
tema de la esclavitud pero también pues
de los negros y de los cimarrones uno de
los momentos cumbres alves de esta
ceremonia fue todo el homenaje que se le
rindió a solicitud esta es una mulata de
la isla de guadalupe junto que junto con
a varios oficiales de esa isla en 1802
pues se sublevaron contra la
reinstauración de la esclavitud algo que
hizo napoleón hambre aparte de solitud
que en español pues esa soledad tuvo un
final un poco triste porque finalmente
esta mulata fue no solamente pues
apresadas sino que estaba embarazada en
esa época y esperaron a que diera a luz
para ejecutarla sin embargo hoy se le
rinde homenaje a ella que es un símbolo
de la esclavitud de la lucha contra la
esclavitud y de hecho la post que es el
correo francés va a emitir una
estampilla en su honor y la ciudad de
parís va a también a instalar una
estatua en su honor en un parque que de
hecho ya lleva su nombre aquí en la
capital